tu sais qu'il n'y a rien de mal avec ma
mémoire
tu es pire à chaque fois que je trouve un
Bryson I Frank
tu dois te moquer de moi cette chose
va me tuer dans mon sommeil
quelqu'un va te tuer dans ton
sommeil réveille Frank aujourd'hui nous  je vais
commencer un jardin
je ne jardine pas alors que le but de mon programme
est d'améliorer ta santé apporte moi juste
une soupe céréale c'est pour les enfants tu
es pour les enfants stupide hé tu as pris ça j'ai
vu que tu l'avais mais le commerçant
t'a distrait même si  c'est du carburant
c'est selon votre dossier vous avez d'abord été
arrêté pour possession de biens volés je me suis
spécialisé dans les diamants julik j'ai besoin d'un
projet ma dope j'ai besoin de quelque chose que vous
ne pouvez pas être stimulé pour me garder
exercé c'était votre meilleur moment pourtant je sais
exactement quoi  la première marque va être
différente,
c'est que vous saviez à propos de votre solution, hé
là, je suis Jennifer, la planification de ce
cambriolage était une excellente idée et très
satisfaite de vos progrès,
comme eh bien, il y a un vol suspect de
plusieurs millions de dollars  bery
c'est impossible
un peu de mal bien sûr tu es
ce qu'il te faut